[Musique]
notre journée sportive puisqu'elle est
le héros que l'on retrouve tout de suite
bonsoir consacré à l'actualité sportive
du week-end les principaux résultats
on va commencer par du football
exactement match changea plaisir le club
local recevait carrière une grésillons
demi-finale de la coupe des yvelines
après une première période rythmée ciel
ce sont finalement les visiteurs qui
ouvrent le score sur un pénalty 1 à 0 ce
sera le score à la mi-temps deuxième
période les affaires de plaisir ne
s'arrange pas on voit le premier penalty
justement voilà à grégory donc en
deuxième période les affaires de plaisir
ne s'arrange pas il concède un deuxième
penalty s'incline finalement 2 à 0 en
écoute les réactions très déçu très déçu
après c'est le football hand on va
commencer par féliciter carrière baca
qui a mérité sa qualification qu'on se
qualifie on le mérite donc bravo à eux
d'abord on a mis les ingrédients pour
gagner ce match on a quarante cinq
premières minutes qui était un peu près
équilibrées on prend un premier but sur
un petit détail presse on reste quand
même dans le match je trouve que la
deuxième mi temps on a totalement dominé
l'adversaire on a eu pas mal d'occasions
nettes on a touché la barre le gardien
aussi il était sur quelques cons on n'a
vraiment pas eu de chance pour plaisir
il faudra espérer avoir un peu plus de
chance l'année prochaine pour soulever
la coupe
de son côté carrière grésillons
rencontrera le club de vélizy en finale
de la coupe des yvelines le 16 juin
prochain à verneuil-sur-seine l on parle
course à pied à présent dimanche 7 avril
lui en cours certains se sont levés très
tôt pour participer à la 25e édition de
la bulle en course au départ du gymnase
des droits de l'homme
une course à pied de 10 km celui qui a
le mieux réussi son réveil matinal c'est
lui pierre etienne charbonnel il
remporte la course en 38 minutes et 40
secondes pour sa première participation
en l'écoutent
le deuxième est juste à queue devait pas
très loin on a fait dix bornes ensemble
et puis j'ai un peu décroché sur le
sur le dernier kilomètre mais c'était
très bien rendez vous l'année prochaine
pour une 26e édition les organisateurs
pourrait modifier légèrement le parcours
est intégrée de la marche nordique au
programme de l'événement et la victoire
chez les féminines liturgie féminines
audrey soulabaille qui a remporté la
compétition
alors je vais vous dire exactement le
temps en 43 minutes et 57 secondes
on retrouve cette interview et son
interview et et l'ensemble des
reportages sport du week-end dans votre
étude sport c'est après ce journal